hey grant oh hey martin
hey i've been using the gcloud command
line tool
from the cloud sdk a lot recently and
i'd like
uh to get a bit more productive with it
do you have any tips or
i sure do i have six tricks up my sleeve
to help you with your productivity when
using g-cloud
cool tell me more
[Music]
as you know i'm trying to learn the
gcloud command line tool a bit more
and there are new flags that i'm
unfamiliar with like all the new
features of cloud run
is there a way i can quickly learn these
new features and flags
yes there is so here's a fun one gcloud
has an
interactive mode where you can see
documentation as you type
to start interactive mode run gcloud
beta interactive
this will start a session in your
terminal providing auto completion
and inline documentation as you type
so for example cloud run has a lot of
feature flags you can specify
if you type gcloud run deploy
dash dash you can go and toggle through
all the flags
oh cool yeah that's max instances that's
the one i was looking for
cool all right
great thank you for that tip for number
two
here's a different issue when i deploy
to cloud functions or the cloud run
i keep getting the same prompts in
gcloud when running those commands
so like it asks me for my location for
my cloud run service
or it asks me to specify i want to
deploy to cloud run managed
or to kubernetes so i have to write
these large scripts with many command
line flags for this
how do i avoid that oh uh do you know
about
g cloud configs no i don't
oh let me show you so gcloud configs
allow you to save configuration options
so you don't need to get
prompted for them and you don't need to
repeat them
so the general syntax is gcloud config
set then your property and value
so for example when deploying to cloud
run you could run the command
of gcloud run deploy
my app and then you provide your
your image but then you might notice oh
you get prompted
okay do you want cloud run fully
and which region do you want right
right so let's go and cancel that
um or you could go and set your config
so you can set your config with gcloud
config
set your run platform
to manage and then maybe your run region
to europe was three
so if i do that then it'll update the
properties
and i can simply re-run the previous
command
and you'll notice now i'm not prompted
automatically just working oh nice
i like fewer prompts
okay cool uh for number three sometimes
i need to include the project id with a
command
i also switch between projects often and
sometimes i use the wrong project
and i have actually in the past
sometimes deployed code to the wrong
project
my manager did not like that is there an
easier way to
manage the projects um
yeah uh there is so i faced this too
it's a little annoying um specifying
your project name everywhere
but um with and and i don't really
like mix up the point between different
projects that's
that's sort of scary um but
but with gcloud you can get and set
your current project so in your scripts
you don't need to hard code
your project id so in the command line
you can set the project with gcloud
config set project
and then your project name
once you have done that then that will
be your default project with all the g
cloud commands and you can also
get your current project and start in an
environment variable
how do you do that well you can go and
type
you can go and type let's say you want
your project
here's a little script to set your
project
inside this environment variable then
you can use this environment variable
anywhere
like when using gcloud so
here's a little example
when using gcloud build submit you can
provide your tag
and you always need your project
and so it'll just recognize that and
work
so i i use this all the time in my
scripts when deploying to cloud run
oh nice no more deploying code to the
wrong project for me
so for number four i switch around
between a few different projects and i
sometimes forget which projects have
billing enabled
many cloud services require billing to
be enabled before using them
so how can i check that grant
oh all right that's a good question
martin so with g
cloud there's a relatively new command
you can use to go and check this
you can run uh the following gcloud
billing beta billing command
so after you run this you get your
project you describe it
and you'll get a boolean value
of true or false and so uh this will
indicate
if billing's enabled for that project
oh cool now i can check if billing is
enabled for all my projects without
having to go to the web browser
and the cloud console over there yep
all right so for number five uh when
i've deployed a private cloud run
service
i can't really test it using curl if i
try to curl it
i get the response error forbidden how
do i fix that
yep so a cloud run service that wasn't
deployed
with dash dash allow unauthenticated
is not accessible with unauthorized
requests
so for example we can go and try curling
a cloud run service and we'll see an
error
for example like 403 forbidden right
yeah not anybody on the public web can
test our proprietary cloud run service
that's what i'm getting yep yep
um but that but that's like really uh
very difficult to test it's great that
we have security but
but we want to be able to test locally
so
by adding our http auth bearer token
when curling we can go and fix this
issue
and so here we'll just provide a header
with our
authorization token from gcloud
and you can see hell martin
it works nice i'll use that for sure
so uh but grant so this worked but
whose access level was used now for this
command
that's a really great question so this
command uses the same
authorization as the person who logged
in to that machine
with gcloud auth login
ah nice all right
for number six uh sometimes when using
google cloud
i'm supposed to use a project number
rather than a
project id this is for example when i'm
using service accounts or creating
service accounts
uh is there a way to get that project
number if i have the project id
oh yeah uh so well with a little bit
of gcloud boo you can go and get one
value
uh from the other so so
with this little command i use this all
the time
you can go and get your project number
if you have your project id
so what it does in the background it
sort of lists your projects and
gets your project id and then formats it
just for that number
so so you might use this with uh
different credentials or
especially like with cloud storage
and likewise let's say you have that
project number
but you want to get your id um
so you can you can do the the reverse
and you can go and list your projects
and get that project id
and there you get your your project id
all right
thanks for showing me these six
incredibly useful tips grant
i didn't know you can do all of that
stuff from the command line
oh uh you're quite welcome martin i mean
i keep discovering
new features and new tips myself i guess
you'll learn something new every day oh
yes i've learned six new things today
thank you everyone for watching we hope
you found these tips useful
and please enter any questions or
comments below
see you next time
you